[Music]
[Applause]
our next guest uh we had beers with him
in Dublin which bonds us for life and
that said none of us enjoy standing next
to him publicly because it causes us to
look completely invisible to the ladies
and that hurts his abs have abs say
hello to Brady
Quinn
oh wej the fist pump okay yeah okay yeah
all
right sorry I was a little bit tarded
this morning I actually flew from
Connecticut to Jacksonville Jacksonville
to Las Vegas okay I me I've never heard
of that before have you guys heard of
anyone who actually would do something
like that to make it to Las Vegas really
not necessary the second sits down it
takes a shot but Todd do you know how
crazy it sounds that you flew from
Harford to Jacksonville to Las Vegas I
was on the plane for 8 hours and 44
minutes but it was very comfortable c3c
that was good that was all right okay I
got some potato chips I had a great trip
too I just a little bit L get in
here oh yeah that was probably not the
best way to go uh great to see you again
great see you if I gave you uh you could
face either one of these
defenses um probably San Francisco and
you've got issues obviously with their
front but they play so much Zone
coverage and for a quarterback you know
especially with the Personnel if you're
talking about Kansas City's if if you
can find those soft spots I mean you can
just dice set up all day you know manto
man it's nice when you can discern who
your matchup is where you're going to go
with the football but it you still you
know the receiver has to get open tight
end has to get open there's an element
of timing that's thrown off too because
of it a lot especially if it's press man
so um that's usually would be my
preference was and you can toy with the
defense with your eyes too so uh I would
I would much rather Goen Stone yeah but
I wonder about this because we saw some
mov mov by Kansas City's defense where
they gave you a look and then they
changed that look on you sure uh and and
how that you know we saw that with San
Francisco too where you think you're
seeing something like how quickly you go
up to the line of scrimmage yeah you see
yeah then you you change the play or
call out the play yeah and then how
quickly can they change their defense
and can you do anything about that it's
usually pretty tough for them to be able
to change once you change especially if
you do it in an efficient manner
um and honestly honestly it doesn't
matter as much when you have like
indicators built into your formation
right so if you displace a tight end a
running back on the outside you
typically know if it's man or Zone if
it's man now I don't care what you do I
know where my matchup is now it's just
Discerning what type of man coverage is
it and is there a pressure coming with
it uh if it's zone now I'm looking for
my match up somewhere else in that zone
coverage so again what type of Zone
matters probably to the progression but
it's usually once you get to whatever
you need to get to the the defense isn't
going to have time before you snap the
football to be able to change what they
want to do the uh quarterback play let
me start with Patrick Mahomes
um you can't really Define that you know
what he does like can you teach what he
does no no I I I think you're born with
that sort of ability and talent and I
think somewhere along the way too you
you go through enough development and
experience where you find some of those
skills and traits along the way but was
he doing this at Texas Tech I called a
number of his games to a degree but not
like what we're seeing now and I think
like this version of where he's at in
his career now to me is the most
impressive because it's like the entire
package like when you talk about the
all-time greats and people are talking
about whether or not he can chase Tom
Brady I would say this season more than
ever for me at least has like convinced
in my mind he can because now it's all
about like he's not trying to
necessarily always create the big play
he's like making the the High football
IQ the smart play that the a play that
ultimately wins you the game and he's
relied a little bit more on his defense
and they've made plays when he's had to
and it's kind of that like Tom Brady
esque early on in his career where it
was very similar in that in that way
whereas Patrick Mahomes early on in his
career could put the team on his back
well their teams built now where they
don't have to do that and he's playing a
style of football too that plays to that
so to to me I think you know as as long
as he continues to develop even maybe
without Travis kely whenever he decides
to hang it up obviously coach Reed at
one point will hang it up he just
continues to develop into like one of
the greatest we've ever seen but also
you brought up something interesting I
think he is more Brady like this year
where he he's relying on his defense and
he's not you know Brady relied on his
defense and and it wasn't you know we
got to put up X number of points and I I
think we saw that with Mahomes that he
has that quality of being patient and
not trying you know with no longer
having Tyre Hill I think he understands
there's nothing wrong with peo there's
nothing wrong with you know you know D
and dunk just hang on to the football
basically yeah I mean that's one of the
things I think stood about Tom Brady and
just having so many coaches and really
Charlie Weiss to when he came to Notre
Dame where you watch the film you watch
the tape was he wasn't afraid to do the
ordinary things extraordinarily well
like he never got bored with just taking
the little check down taking the play
here taking this and that and and
there's a lot of power into that where
you can let a lot of teams beat
themselves and you can just keep going
out there and executing and then
prolonging the game and I guess since
we're in Vegas I'll use I'll use this
analogy like he knows when to double
down like he knows when to take his
shots Tom Brady did that we see that
more from Patrick Mahomes this year too
and I think the great ones are like that
you know they they understand it at
certain points time in the game when you
have to or when you don't and you can
preserve your right to punt the football
because you're going to get another
opportunity to get the football back
he's Brady Quinn Fox college football
analyst big noon kickoff and also one of
the host of two Pros in a cup of joe the
former Notre Dame quarterback if I
hadn't seen Brock pie play how would you
describe
it that's the hard thing is uh I would
say he's gritty he's tough um he's a
football player and I know that sounds
like a little cliche but uh to me a
football player defines like that guy's
going to do whatever he needs to do to
try to win a football game and it's
honestly the ultimate compliment but um
everyone else has these other tags for
him which I find interesting because a
lot of where he excels or where he has
extraordinary Talent are the things that
aren't Quantified or are hard to
quantify and uh it's been fun watching
him just from his time I was say played
a lot of football then getting his
opportunity within this system Excel and
he operates it as well as anyone has
probably under Kyle Shanahan yeah I
don't know how often we've looked at a
quarterback and said well look at all
the weapons we did this to Terry
Bradshaw yeah Terry Bradshaw was like
well anybody can quarterback the
Steelers with you know two that defense
that offense yes exact running backs the
offensive line everything can you think
of another quarterback that we said well
he's winning look at all the talent
around him and and we're doing that with
Brock pie yeah I mean people always
bring up what the the Brad Johnson Tampa
Bay Bucks team not near the talent
around but defensively too look at the
Baltimore Ravens too everyone brings up
Trent dfur which again I think there's
but dfur wasn't an MVP candidate and
Brock p is an MVP candidate and I think
people have a hard time
acknowledging you know he does what he's
supposed to do right it it's like the
guy who shows up for work for 30 years
and never misses a day and you know put
it this way like he distributes the
football well right yeah like would we
be okay at this day and age giving um
the MVP to Steve Nash like remember back
when he won it and he dished the ball
time he'd be like right there and you're
like just take the layup and he just
dish it to someone else to go and score
and I wonder in today's NBA if that
would be enough to win an MVP because
that's essentially what his job is is is
it's Distributing the football and he
does it again extremely well and what's
wrong with that leaning on the talent
that he's got around him yeah I I think
it's a compliment to him that he's able
to do that there are a lot of I mean how
many offenses win a Super Bowl and you
go man he did that without any good
players right like they all have good
players yeah and and and I think he
helps them excel in the sense of he gets
the football to them in the right spot
at the right time which is extremely
important he's accurate and then he can
create too we saw that especially in the
NFC championship game when he needed to
he used his legs to create and do some
things downfield and so again I I I
think he's got he encompasses everything
that you're looking for and so throw
whatever tag you want on him if he win
Sunday he's going to be a Super Bowl
champion and no one can take that away
from him I also think he benefited by
playing at Iowa State where he didn't
have you know it's not a marquee
football program and it felt like he had
be careful there D he passionate fans
their names Iowa I'm saying well uh they
had a better offense than Iowa
had wow wow I think we could get a group
together and have a better offense than
I was I think you guys need to host a
show for the shawk next year I get out
there for that robbery game but I think
he had to throw people open in col like
I think it was tougher you know and you
know not playing at Oklahoma or USC or
Ohio State or Georgia I think he really
had to work and that benefited him with
you know what he does in the NFL where
you do have to throw somebody open yeah
I think there's a maybe a degree of that
I mean I want to take away from some of
the players they had over the time he
was there they had some talented players
um I don't even know if it's so much
that I think some of what he went
through probably during his time at Iowa
State is just understanding how to lead
especially through adversity
understanding what loses games what can
win you games like there's a lot of Po
important lessons because ultimately
quarterback is about decision- making
and so the more you play the better you
get it kind of understanding hey it's
actually okay to take a sack here like
if we did the tree of life okay and
there's my old quarterback coach Tater
Smith talked about this one time the
quarterback room you always say you know
there's getting married there's having
kids there's always winning the Super
Bowl always great things and he goes and
as you go down the tree of life of like
ah you know all the other bad things
that are out there he's like people will
tell you taking a sack is like the worst
thing in the world he's like it's not
all right a sack fumble interception
like all those are much worse right you
know obviously other things that are out
there could be worse he like in the tree
of life it's okay to take a sack we'll
take time off the clock preserve the
right the point you'll get another shot
back at it and um I think there's like
little lessons like that that I think he
he learned over his time in Iowa State
as it tree of life I didn't think the
Tree of Life Would going to be on my
bingo card here but hey I got to give
it's all Tater it's all Tater Smith got
to give Carl Smith credit uh if you ran
the Bears yeah you would do what I I
would keep Fields cuz I'm a Believer in
Justin fields and I think what they've
done with those picks to build around
him has been successful now I know in
saying that it doesn't take into account
the business side of things you're going
to have to sign up to an extension
sooner whereas you could take a Caleb
Williams or Drake May whoever your
quarterback is and you get him on that
rookie contract that that's all good
that's great too um I'm still a believer
in Justin Fields though I I think he's
continued to develop the more they've
given him and I think he will continue
to do that moving forward especially
with my guy Sugar Shane Waldren so yeah
but see I think if if you if you take
Caleb Williams it gives the coaching
staff another couple of
years now you're making that decision
for Matt Eber flu right yes like who are
we ultimately making the decision for
the the better men of the organization
are you just makeing it so you can hang
on to the head coach like I I personally
view those things as exclusive whether
you take Caleb Williams or whether you
keep Justin Fields you're evaluating
your head coach based on what he's doing
with what he has on the roster and is he
putting those guys in the best position
to succeed so if you're just trying to
buy got more time to like prove you
wrong or right no if I'm the coach I
want a new quarterback but isn't it Ryan
PA's decision well you know who
ultimately makes that decision I would
imagine the GM would yeah uh did you do
your Super Bowl pick uh I I would make
it fairly simple okay uh I will have to
go with the Chiefs obviously spent a
year there uh love the hunt family love
a lot of the folks there just a lot of
good people Ted Cruz best um uh so I'm
I'm rude for them I just think
ultimately it's going to be a tight game
when it comes down to it it's hard to
ever pick against Patrick Mahomes Ted
Cruz the politician is that what you're
talking about no no okay I wasn't
sure T people who know people know Ted
Cruz within the can't see okay I just I
was curious there didn't know what Ted
Cruz had to do I'm talk I'm not talking
about Eagle Eagle Pass or none of that
we not talking about any of that D fair
enough fair fair enough media relations
yes thank
you I I assume you've had on a chief
before where someone's talked to for
Wiman was with a few no nobody's brought
up Ted Cruz who works for the Chiefs
that's why you got to give my guy a
shout out he does a great job Todd do
you know Ted Cruz I know Ted Cruz I know
Brad G GE he's a chief set of media
relations and I mean I don't know I'm
gonna give Ted Cruz credit for bringing
Together Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift
so I'll just I'll leave that out there
so I don't know wait they're the mat I
could have completely just fabricated
that but also do we know it's not true
so there's that okay we don't we don't
okay I mean we do know fritzy for some
reason took a flight from Connecticut to
Jacksonville jackville 2 Vegas we do
know that I did do that trying to get
status like what was the point of that
that was just a bad choice yes Paul
Brady he I think he's taking the same
flight back it has the same route back
this one actually goes to northwalk
Virginia then to Connecticut which is
not that's great either yeah you
couldn't get a direct anywhere back like
where you just land and drive I got all
excited that it was c3c was available on
Breeze Air and I'm like you know what
I'll go to Jacksonville and I'll sit in
the
leg Drew Brees has his own Airlines
that's right no I've I went to a game he
was at I want to say it was two years
ago I've seen his plane he's got a
really nice plane and well I might say
Breeze Air on the side or something that
was a very nice plane so uh he's Brady
Quinn two Pros in a cup of Joe and big
noon kickoff always great to see you
thank you
Brady somebody's yelling at Brady back
there my pants are too hot oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah they may be today I'm still
self-conscious about that so thank you
thank you will frell thank you for that
uh we're back after this with Troy Aman